hi there Steve Kaufman this is for the
world's biggest coffee on line or
something I can't remember the name of
it it's a blog they in order to promote
awareness of cancer I believe and raise
money for cancer they want to get as
many languages as possible on this blog
post it came at me somehow on Facebook I
never quite know how these things happen
so I'm going to do five videos here and
because I'm gonna group them as follows
I'm gonna do one video with the Germanic
languages which is gonna be this one and
thereafter there won't be any more
English I'm gonna do one video therefore
with four Germanic languages I'm gonna
do one with I think five Slavic
languages five Romance languages for
Asian languages and finish off with the
two modern versions of ancient languages
that I'm now studying in preparation my
trip to israel and greece so first of
all let me say off the bat head spade
meters to Zeta X break hey Netherlands
so let's get the Dutch out of the way I
don't speak Dutch but that counts for
one of the languages for the blog post
sense Kai Proctor it is fancy Adam yeah
cantata svenska so at first okay
some your first or ever at we thought
the finished manga stroke Eve Adam
official track protomans prota
oh they been scouring his [ __ ] olin dumb
air your meniscus broke okay so Arioch
so Miska on TS very submission our
ambition of deutsche strengthened on the
other HW Olin here tightness the eluded
can't Canon as a registrar I want we are
all and done and child beasts oomph MC
machinist from here as of Ferelden doses
Alice yes hobbies fear for Cigna
- rockin gets Wakan Tanka beat us in
hate Oh bye-bye